du blé local des machines françaises
c'est le credo des moulins de versailles
l'entreprise fondée par la famille shaw
des produits des farines pour les
particuliers et les professionnels
une passion qui perdure depuis plus d'un
siècle il faut l'y de chevet avère un
moulin à étampes dans l'essonne
son fils romain chaudet
avait un moulin à yerres dans l'essonne
le film sort en main chaude et george
clooney s'est installé ici à versailles
en 1905
aujourd'hui cette personne travaille
qu'ici les moulins de versailles ce sont
1500 tonnes de farine par an et 30
tonnes par jour alors là vous voyez par
exemple
sur de la farine lassé d'attendre on va
passer cette farine la havane stockés
dans des silos de silos qui traverse le
moulin lcd silo qui sont la
particularité d'être calorifuge et
on n'était qu'un barbosa
un rendez vous
tiens ce qui permet
d'abord in fine au modèle des produits
fabriqués à partir d'un blé cultivé à
moins de 100 km de versailles pour
obtenir de bonnes farine la sélection
est rigoureuse on a ne crois pas qu'il
va chercher le blay donc ça nous permet
de le contrôler au départ à l'arrivée
le blé a analysé chaque plaît à une
signature et qui défendent ces
caractéristiques
ensuite selon l'appareil de combat
produire pendant la nette pour la
journée on va
1-1 dosage précis de chaque cellule pour
pouvoir faire une foraine qui est
toujours constante qualité homogène
depuis un an les moulins de versailles
se renouvelle la marque envisage de
lancer une gamme bio autre nouveauté des
préparations sucrées fondant au chocolat
madeleine autant de recettes à découvrir
au salon de la pâtisserie